DEEPTI SRIVASTAVA: Hello,
and welcome to Cloud OnAir
from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Deepti
Srivastava, and I'll
be talking to you today about
Cloud Spanner and how it works.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have Googlers
standing by to answer them,
and I'll also take
some questions
after the presentation
part is over.
So let's get started.
So Cloud Spanner--
we've talked about it
in a few other webinars as well.
But today, we wanted to take
a deeper dive into how we get
eventual-- sorry--
global external consistency
with this system
with asset transactions
and good performance.
So let's do a little
recap, in case you're
joining us for the first time,
of what Cloud Spanner is.
So here is a suite of our
managed database and storage
services on Google
Cloud Platform.
So as you can see,
we have a wide array
of services to meet all
needs of your applications
from the storage and
database standpoint.
We have Cloud Storage, which
is our binary object store.
We have our key values stored
in Memcache App Engine.
And then we have a data
store and Cloud Bigtable,
which is our
non-relational offerings.
And on the relational side,
we have Cloud SQL and Cloud
Spanner, which is our scale-out,
our relational database
service.
And on the other end,
we have BigQuery,
which is our enterprise
data warehouse.
So with Cloud Spanner
and Cloud BigQuery,
we have the full suite of
scale-out relational database
as well as scale-out
enterprise data warehouse.
So what is Cloud
Spanner, really?
So it's the only
enterprise-grade,
globally distributed,
and strongly
consistent managed database
service built for the cloud
specifically to combine the
benefits of relational database
structure and non-relational
horizontal scale.
What does that mean?
So basically, with
Cloud Spanner,
you don't have to
make tradeoffs.
You can get schemas, asset
transactions across rows,
regions, and continents, along
with SQL querying, so not
something that sort of
resembles SQL, but actual SQL
with ANSI 2011 SQL
compliance query engine.
And you get the benefits
of a horizontally scalable
no-SQL system.
So we offer up to five
nines of availability,
and that's a lot of nines.
But what that really
means is we guarantee
less than five
minutes of downtime
a year, which is
industry-leading for the SLA.
It is a fully managed and
easily scalable service.
So what that means is you
can-- with a few clicks,
you can deploy a globe-spanning
database, and be ready to go.
So let's get into how
we are able to achieve
this no-tradeoff
industry leading system.
So what is the foundation
on which we're established?
So first of all, as
you can see here,
Google Cloud
Platform has a number
of regions and more coming.
In fact, we added something
like 39 zones last year alone,
and we continue to
invest in the platform
and in the infrastructure
for our customers.
So as I said, we
added 39 new zones,
and we continue to add more.
And as you can see, we
have data centers and zones
across the world
to provide services
close to where the customers are
and where the applications need
to be for our customers to
provide the best application
performance to their end users.
Now on this platform, we have
built Cloud Spanner instances.
So we have instances
in two flavors.
There are regional
Cloud Spanner instances
and multi-region instances.
So in this case, with
regional Cloud Spanner,
you can see we're available
in multiple regions on GCP
across the world, and we're
adding more regions as we go.
In fact, our aim
is to basically be
part of the initial footprint
in all regions moving forward
as we launch more
regions on GCP.
What this means is that we
have replicated instant--
like basically, we
have three zones
that are replicating
inside each region.
So if you have data locality or
data governance concerns, then
with Cloud Spanner
regional instances,
you can put your entire
database in one region,
and the data remains
in that region.
The other flavor
as I talked about
is multi-region configurations.
And the first one we
are talking about here
is a continental multi-region.
So as you can see, there
are two data centers,
where the Cloud Spanner
configuration exists,
which means there are five
zones across those two data
centers that support
the databases you
create in that instance.
Then there is a multi-region
global instance,
which is North America,
Europe, and Asia.
So here, what's important
to note is that when we look
at the green bounding
box for both the regional
and the multi-region--
sorry, the regional single
continent and multi-continent
configurations, that
you're really talking
to one Cloud Spanner database.
And that one database is being
replicated across the zones
and regions we
talked about here,
but that's transparent to you.
So in this case,
we have replicas
across nine zones
in the four regions
that are marked here for
the North America, Europe,
and Asia configuration.
And for you, you talk to one
Cloud Spanner database that
is transparently replicated
across those nine zones,
but you never have to
choose which zone to go to
or which replica to talk to.
That's something that
the API takes care of.
Now, that's about like the
physical location of the data,
but how is that data connected?
How are those data
centers that GCP has,
how are their zones
and regions connected?
So as you know, or
you may have heard of,
Google Cloud has
its own network.
In fact, Google built its own
networking fabric a while ago
and continues to
invest in it, which
means that we connect
our data centers,
and we want to put
requests and user traffic
on our network as quickly
as possible, which
is different from
other cloud providers,
because usually, they have
to deal with the hot potato
problem, where if their
network gets congested,
they offload to the
public internet,
whereas in Google's
case, we actually
want to put your requests on our
network as quickly as possible,
because we have built the
network to be redundant.
We have multiple links
to the same place,
so multiple routes to the
same two connection points.
And we've built the stack up
to be resilient and highly
performant, so we
can predict latencies
across these
different endpoints.
And therefore, we can
give better performance,
and we don't have to rely
on the routing constraints
and latencies of the public
internet in most cases.
And as I was talking
about earlier,
let's go into the
hot potato problem.
So basically, what a
typical cloud provider does
is they try to offload user
traffic to the public internet
as quickly as possible,
because they don't have
as much bandwidth provision.
So in most cases, the
network gets congested,
especially as they're new--
especially if there's
higher traffic
volumes that are happening.
So as soon as that
happens, a lot
of people are asking for the
same data across same data
points--
end points.
Then the traffic gets offloaded
to the public internet, which
has its own congestion
problems and its own sort
of traffic issues.
So there isn't predictable
performance and latency
in that case.
But with Google Cloud and
with Google in general,
we try to put user
traffic as quickly as
possible on the Google
network so that, as I said,
we have built the stack very
carefully so that we can
predict performance for
the network in this case,
and therefore, can
offer good performance
and predictable latencies to
the customers of Google Cloud.
Now, let's get to the specifics
of Cloud Spanner itself.
So there are multiple concepts
that you may have come across
with Cloud Spanner.
There is nodes,
replicas, and the data
that lives in Cloud Spanner.
So with Cloud Spanner, you buy
nodes, and you get storage.
And they scale independently,
so you can keep
adding data to Cloud Spanner.
You can keep writing
data to your database,
and the storage
will automatically
scale to absorb that data.
And the compute
for that database
is coming from the nodes
that you provision.
That's something you
have to provision,
and it's a few clicks that you
go to the UI, to our console,
and then just add nodes,
and within a few seconds
to a minute or a few minutes,
you get the additional nodes.
And then the data is
automatically sharded
across those new
nodes, which means
you won't have to take care
of physical provisioning,
obviously, but you
also don't have
to take care of the data
sharding and rebalancing.
That's something that Cloud
Spanner takes care of.
The system takes care of itself.
So let's get into the concepts
of how these things work
and differ from each other.
So let's talk about the
regional configuration first.
So as I mentioned
before, Cloud Spanner
is replicated across multiple
zones either within a region
or in the multi-region
case across multiple zones
in multiple GCP regions.
So in the regional
configuration,
we have three replicas that are
in three different availability
zones within a
single GCP region.
So in this case, we're
looking at, let's
say, European region 1,
which has availability zones
A, B, and C within which a Cloud
Spanner instance will exist.
So when you go to the console
and create a Cloud Spanner
instance, and you choose
a regional configuration,
any regional
configuration, it will
come with three
availability zones
within which your
instance will exist.
And all the data and
all the databases
that you create
within that instance
will be replicated in
this configuration.
And as you can see here, there
are three read-write replicas
in the three availability zones.
Now, going to a more
interesting picture,
let's look at our
global configuration,
which is our NAM-EUR-ASIA-1
configuration that we looked
at earlier.
In this case, as I
had mentioned earlier,
there are nine
replicas across three
different continents and nine
different availability zones.
So in this particular
case, if you notice,
the right quorum
has five replicas
that are all in the US, in
North America in this case.
And there are two replicas
each in Asia and Europe
for read-only workloads.
So the way to think about the
multi-region configurations
is that you're trading off
write latency, a little bit
higher write latency
for very low read
latency close to your
clients and users.
So data from Cloud
Spanner is always
going to be served from the
closest, healthiest replica
that it can satisfy the
request that the user has made.
And in this case, yes, all
write requests go to the US,
and we'll get into that.
But because we have
our network that I
talked about that has
predictable low latencies
and is redundant and
has multiple routes
to two different
endpoints, because of that,
we can actually offer pretty low
latency and good performance,
even for the writes going
all the way to the US.
So digging one layer
deeper, let's, again,
look at the regional
configuration first.
When you create a Cloud
Spanner instance, as I said,
you get three replicas.
Transparently, you never know
that there are three replicas
in your instance.
You could choose a
regional instance
or a multi-region configuration
for your instance,
and the number of
replicas and all
of that, essentially,
implementation detail will
be hidden from you.
What you do is
talk to an instance
and a database
within that instance.
And as I mentioned
earlier, you can actually
create multiple databases
within a Cloud Spanner instance,
if you need the same
replication topology for them.
So in this case, we have two
databases within the Cloud
Spanner instance
that are replicated
across the three zones that
exist for this Cloud Spanner
configuration.
So let's look at the
next layer of how writes
and updates work in
this configuration.
So when an update comes
in, the system knows--
so first of all, you're, again,
talking to one Cloud Spanner
database within a configuration,
so you're basically
exposed to one Cloud Spanner
endpoint for the database.
You don't ever have
to think about or code
in your application which
replica you should go to.
That's not a decision
that you have to make.
That's something that
the system and the API
will take care of, which
means that in this case,
if an update comes in
for Table 1 and Table 2,
so if you want to
update key 1 and key 2
in Table 1 and Table
2, then the API
figures out where the
leader of these keys
is and will send the
request to that leader.
So we use Paxos as the consensus
mechanism for our write
commits, so there's
more information
on Paxos on the link.
But basically, it's
a consensus protocol
that says that as long as
a majority of replicas,
essentially, agree--
as long as the majority
agrees, then you
can commit the transaction
or commit data.
So in this case, this is
why we have three replicas,
so as long as two out
of the three replicas
agree on any change, then
that change can be persisted.
So in this case, going
back to our example,
if you wanted to update Table
1 and Table 2 as in key 1
and key 2 in Table
1 and Table 2,
the protocol will route
the message, the request
to the leader of the replica--
sorry, leader of these keys
need a replica for these keys.
And then that leader is
responsible for sending
the request out to
the other two replicas
and getting an acknowledgment
back and committing the data.
And by the time you get
an acknowledgment for that
commit back, the
data has already
been-- the mutation has
already been shipped out
to the other two replicas.
So if you do a read after write,
like if you make a read request
as soon as you get an update
commit acknowledgment back,
then you are guaranteed to see
the latest update of the data.
This is the coolness
of Cloud Spanner
and its global
external consistency,
that you can actually do a
read after a committed app,
and you're guaranteed
to see the latest data.
And you don't have
to ever think about
whether the data was
eventually consistent,
which means that if you
asked two different replicas,
will you get two
different answers?
In fact, you can ask for
the data from anywhere
in the world, and you will
get the same answer back
guaranteeing the
external consistency
that we talked about.
Now, let's get into the
more interesting example
of the multi-region
configurations and the reads
and write requests there.
So starting with
the write request,
if there's an update to be
made from a US client, then
basically, the client can just--
the API will route the
client request for the write
to the read-write quorum,
which is in the US,
and then the request
response will be routed back
to the client from the US.
So there's a round-trip between
the US client and the US quorum
and back.
In case there is
a client in Asia--
and again, if you remember,
we have the read-write quorum
in the US with five replicas
across three different data
centers, and then we
have read-only replicas
in Asia and in Europe.
So if you have a client in Asia
making a read-write request
as in an update request
for the database,
basically, we'll try and put the
request on the Google network,
on a Google front end
as quickly as possible
as close to the Asia
client as possible.
So within Asia, we'll basically
put the request on our network,
and from there, it'll be routed
to the read-write client--
sorry, the read-write
quorum in the US.
And the acknowledgment will
come back to the Asia client.
So the writes, as I said,
are routed to the US,
but because we put the
request as quickly as possible
on the Google network,
we have guaranteed
sort of low latencies.
And we have predictable
performance for these requests.
Now, if you make a strong read,
which is a consistent read, so
basically, if you update
a key, and then you
make a request to read the key
from Asia, again, then because
of the global
external consistency,
we guarantee that you will see
the latest update in this case.
So the important
thing to note here
is that the data is being
served from the local replica.
The deal is not
actually being shipped
from the US read-write
quorum, which
is an important distinction,
because what we're saying
is that as we commit, as
part of the commit protocol,
the leaders actually ship
out the mutations, not
the data itself,
but the mutations
to all other replicas.
And then the replicas
apply the data themselves,
so it's a fully distributed
system, where each replica acts
independently with
consensus and making sure
that we get the accurate data
and the consistency guarantees.
But each replica is applying
this mutation independently
in its own data structures.
So what that means is
unlike other systems, where
we have one master
replica, and then
the data is being shipped out
to the other slave replicas,
in this case, all
the replicas behave
as one global
database, which means
that even though the read-write
quorum exists in the US
as part of committing
that write,
the mutations are sent across
to all read-only replicas,
and then they apply the
mutations independently.
And then the data is served
from the closest healthy replica
to the client
making the request.
What that means is in
this case, the data
is being served from the
read-only replica in Asia,
which means, of course,
it's lower latency and more
predictable performance.
So you don't have to get the
data from the US or from,
essentially, the quorum
in a different continent.
So you're not shipping
huge blocks of data
across oceanic links, which
means it doesn't take as long,
and therefore, we can have
better performance and lower
latency.
That is just one of
the optimizations
we've made to both
the Paxos protocol
and to the entire
Cloud Spanner stack
to be able to perform these
multi-region reads and writes
efficiently for
the applications.
Now, when you're
making a strong read,
there is a ping to the
quorum, which is in the US,
to make sure that the Asia
replica has the latest data
and knows what the last
commit time for that key was.
So again, you're making a
ping round-trip to the US,
but you're not actually
shipping the data.
The data itself is
served from Asia.
Now, this is another interesting
feature of Cloud Spanner
that we have these
bounded read requests.
So because Cloud Spanner is
a multi-version concurrency
control system, it
means that we actually
maintain older
versions of the data up
to a certain bounded time.
And if you choose
bounded staleness,
or if you choose a read request
of a certain staleness of time,
then the chances
of the data being
served from their local
replica are much, much higher.
So you don't even have
to-- because you're not
asking for the latest
data, you don't even
have to contact the quorum
in a different continent
to ask for what the last
commit time for this key was.
You can actually just serve
the data from the local replica
without having that
RTT to the leader.
So this actually leads
to the very low latency
reads from anywhere close to
all of these multiple regions
for the multi-region
configurations.
This is the tradeoff,
which gets even more
acute when you look at
your boundedly stale reads
and writes.
So the writes will
go to the US--
in this case, to the quorum.
But the reads, especially
stale reads or bounded reads,
up to a particular time can be
served from the local replica.
So if you say, I want to
get the value of these keys
up to 15 minutes ago,
up to 15 seconds ago,
you will get the data locally
from the local replica.
Let's get into another layer,
which is automatic sharding
and life of query and how--
what we talked about
are high level.
Like how does it actually get
served from Cloud Spanner?
So again, going back
to our regional picture
of three replicas, here, we have
three replicas with the compute
and storage highlighted.
So when you provision one
node in Cloud Spanner,
it's actually one
node per region.
Sorry, one node per
availability zone.
So this means that in the
regional configuration,
you're actually getting one
node in Zone A, one in Zone B,
and one in Zone C.
So there are actually
three nodes worth of
compute that you're getting
across these three zones.
And in this configuration
in the picture,
we actually have
three nodes, which
is our minimum for
guaranteeing the SLA.
So in this case, when you
sort of provision three nodes,
you're actually getting
nine nodes total,
right is hidden from you.
Again, you don't have to worry
about the complexity of how
these things break down
in terms of provisioning.
You just think of one node and
one node's worth of compute
for your database
and your instance.
So as I said,
storage and compute
are the two axes of
Cloud Spanner that
scale mostly independently.
In the storage case, we
actually shard the data.
That's what allows us to
be as scalable as we are.
And the sharding
is both automatic,
and resharding happens
automatically as well.
So the data
assignment of a shard,
which here in Cloud Spanner
terminology is a split,
is done by the system.
And assignment of those
shards or splits to the nodes
is also done automatically
by the system.
So the same shards exist
across all three zones,
which is where we're
getting consistently
sharding the same way
across three zones.
But the assignment
of those shards
can be different, depending on
the load and the other workload
characteristics.
Again, this entire thing
is done automatically,
so you don't ever have to worry
about resharding or rebalancing
your data.
So in the regional
configuration,
let's look at this split.
So a database has
multiple splits,
so a database has
multiple tables that
have multiple keys in them.
And basically, a set of
keys together is a split.
So we basically are
splitting the database
across a full set
of keys, and each
split-- as I said, the
splits happen consistently
across the three zones.
So each split within one
zone is the same split
on the other zones as well.
And together, they
form a Paxos group.
And so in this illustrative
example, like Split 1
has this one Paxos group
across three zones.
And that is repeated
for all the splits.
Each split, essentially,
forms a group
along which we run
the Paxos protocol.
There's some optimizations
here, but basic terminology
is the same.
And basically, that's
what we're doing.
So how are these splits done?
As I was talking about earlier,
basically, we have a key range.
A table has multiple
keys, and the key space
itself is what
we're partitioning.
so a database has tables.
It has keys, and those
keys have a key range,
and each key range
forms a split.
So in this case, if we have keys
from 0 to 2000, as you can see,
we have four splits.
And the splits don't
have to be even.
They can be in terms
of the number of keys.
It depends on the
workload, as I said.
So if certain keys are getting
more work, more queries
on them, they have
a higher QPS, then
they will be put on
a separate split,
because we do both
size-based splitting
and load-based splitting.
And again, this
is all automatic,
so as load increases,
load base splitting
will split it into
further splits.
And if there is less
load, then the splits
will merge to form
bigger splits,
because the nodes or the
splits can handle the data--
sorry, the workload
that's coming in.
So in this case, we
have four splits.
And each of those splits has
a group with a group leader.
And as you can see,
the split is the same
in Zone A, Zone B, and Zone C.
So high level, basically, we're
saying that each replica
has the same split of data,
and that split combination
becomes the group.
And each group has a leader.
And so when strong reads
and writes come in,
they go to the group leader,
who is then responsible for,
in the case of writes,
for getting consensus on
whether the write
should commit or not.
And in the case of strong reads,
it's responsible for saying,
here's the last update
that happened to this split
or to the specific
key in the split.
So again, just to
recap, we have database
with a bunch of keys,
which makes the key space.
And the spanner splits up that
key space into multiple splits.
And the split is
replicated across all zones
within an instance
configuration.
And each split
group has a leader.
Now, again, the
important thing to note
is that leadership
can also change and is
done automatically
based on health
and a bunch of other
heuristics and metrics
that we're constantly
monitoring.
So for Spanner, changing
leader is not necessarily
a failure-only scenario.
It's actually done all the time.
We're constantly
changing the split group
leader, because we're looking
at a bunch of heuristics
and metrics and
making sure that we
can have the most optimal
leadership performance, which
is why we can change
the split leader,
split group leader on
the fly all the time.
So now, we need to talk
about how these splits are
assigned to the nodes.
So if you remember
our previous picture,
we have nodes that are compute
units that can come and go,
essentially.
And then there's storage,
which is the database
and how it's split across with
these splits across these keys.
But then these splits
have to be operated upon,
and so they're assigned
to nodes within a zone.
And each zone assigns splits
to nodes independently based
on the health metrics and
many other heuristics.
Again, this is
done automatically,
so if a node goes
down, then the split
is rebalanced to
a different node.
Or if we just so
choose, because of load
and other
characteristics, we just
move splits between
nodes all the time.
So in this case, we're
saying that Node 1
from our three-node example
in the regional instance
configuration that we had
talked about earlier, split 0
goes to Node 1.
Split 1 goes to Node 2, and
then split 2 and 3 go to Node 3.
And if conditions are such that
we think one of these splits
is getting overloaded, then
either there'll be a new split
and go to a different
node, or split 3
itself can go to
a different node.
So as I said, it's important to
understand that a key range is
how we look at--
Spanner looks at the data in
the database as a key range.
And we basically split
it across that key range.
So as I said, we could
have multiple splits.
We don't even have to have
splits matching anything else,
but it's not like if
you have three nodes,
we'll have three splits.
We actually have
multiple splits,
and the splits can be merged
and extracted out as well.
So because we look at the entire
database as a set of keys,
as a key range, choice
of key is important.
And this is true for basically
all relational databases,
because the relationships are
primarily defined through keys.
The key choice can dramatically
affect performance.
For example, if you're
wanting to query
a set of keys or a set
of data that is not
in primary key order, then
you have to create an index,
where the index keys are
in the order in which you
expect to be querying them
for faster response and faster
scans.
In general-- and this is,
again, true for most databases.
It's recommended to not
use sequential numbers
or timestamps as keys, because
again, we are splitting up keys
and then sharding the
data across the key range
in those splits,
and then putting
the splits on multiple nodes.
So if we have to--
if you're sequentially
adding numbers or timestamps
to your key range, then
that means everything
in a particular split in
a particular key range
is being affected.
And that entire split is
being served by a node,
so therefore, it
becomes a hotspot.
And again, for most
relational databases,
this is a common anti-pattern.
But especially for Spanner,
it's definitely not recommended
that you choose your
ascending and descending
sequential numbers
or timestamps.
So if you need to
do that, then we
recommend making it second,
third, or fourth part
of a composite key,
because the Spanner can
take composite keys.
So you can actually put these
ascending and descending
numbers as a set, as a non-first
part of the primary key
so that we can split across
those and shard the data.
So basically, when you're
designing your schema,
you want to think
about how it can
be sharded and
parallelized, because that's
the power of Spanner is to be
able to shard and parallelize--
shard data and parallelize
operations on that data
automatically.
So if you allow the system
to split across keys,
then it can be better at
parallelizing the workload,
thereby giving you better
throughput and better
performance.
And there are more information
on this on our documentation
page on cloud.google.com
/spanner/docs/bestpractices.
So life of a strong read--
so if you're trying to get
the latest data, what happens
is your request goes to the
closest replica to you, which
will look up the
split information,
and then will ask
the leader, what
is the latest
commit on that data?
And then it gets a response
back on what the latest commit
timestamp was, and then it
will respond with the data
at that timestamp.
So again, to dig
deeper, if we say,
read from my table
key 123, then the user
makes that request that
gets put on our Google
network, Google front end or
the Cloud Spanner front end,
and then goes to the zone
that is closest to you that
can serve that information.
And in this case, because
it's a strong read
as in the latest data written--
the request is for that--
we have to, as I had
mentioned earlier,
we have to send a
ping to the leader
to say, OK, what was the
last time at which data
was committed for this key?
And with that information, it
can serve the data from locally
to the user.
Now, the obvious
question here is,
what happens if the
data hasn't been sent?
In this case, the
mutation hasn't
been sent to the
non-leader splits, which
is a great question.
What happens is, as I said
earlier, as part of the commit,
we're actually sending
out the mutations
to all the other replicas.
So chances are that
it's already been
received by split 2,
zone A in this case,
and will be served by the
zone A split to the requester.
If it is the case that
the zone A, split 2
hasn't received
data at time T bang
is mentioned here, which is
the latest timestamp of commit,
then there might be a
little bit of a wait
to get to that
timestamp, and then
get the data of that timestamp,
and then respond back.
But as I said, in most
cases, because we're
sending the data out
parallely, there shouldn't be--
these latencies are generally
hidden within the commit time
itself.
In terms of a
boundedly stale read,
as I talked about
earlier, if you
make a request for this key,
123 again, but with a maximum
15-second staleness, what that
means is the local replica
is confident that it has
the data at that time.
The older you go,
the more chances
are that the mutations
have been replicated
to the other
replicas, which means
that it can serve this
request without even
having to talk to the leader.
So in terms of
single row writes,
so basically, what
this means is that we
are trying to commit data to
a single key or a single row
in this configuration.
In this case, it's a
three-zone configuration,
but the same applies to a
multi-reading configuration
as well.
So basically, the request-- it
makes a write request, and then
the write request goes
directly to the leader.
And again, the
API and the system
itself know where the leader
is, so the write request
is directly routed
to the leader.
The leader acquires locks.
That's the whole
point of leadership
is to be the sole proprietor
of committing data to those--
committing changes to that
data, and therefore, it
has the locks.
So it'll acquire the
locks, and then it
will send the write request
to the other replicas
within the form-- in this
case, the two other replicas
in this configuration.
And the replicas
will basically acq--
so it's basically two-faced
commit where the replicas will
acqs that they're
ready to write,
that they agree
with this proposal.
And once the split leaders,
the two leader in zone B
gets acqs back from a
majority, so basically,
from one other zone in this
case, two out of three or three
out of five, it'll
release the logs,
and it'll apply the
changes locally, and then
send a successor request
back to the requester.
So again, as I was
saying earlier,
as part of the commit
protocol, the writes
are actually mutations are
actually being sent out,
which means that
you don't actually
have to wait for the data
to be applied at the leader,
and then have the data be
replicated to other replicas.
The mutations are being
replicated as part of a commit,
and therefore, they're
being applied independently.
And chances are that if
you read the same data
after the commit
responses come back,
that you will get
the data immediately
from the local replica.
Let's look at a more
interesting case,
which is writing across
two different splits.
So if you want to write across--
in a table or
multiple tables, which
happen to be on two
different splits,
then those splits will
have to coordinate in order
to commit the write.
So let's look at
an example where
we are going to commit data,
such that split 1 and split 2
are involved.
And as you can see
from this diagram,
split 1 has leader in
zone C, and split 2
has leader in zone B.
So when a write request comes in
to commit data to row X and Y,
as part of that write
request, the coordinator
is already chosen
by the client, which
means chosen by the API itself.
In this case, we have
chosen zone C leader
to be the coordinator.
So each of these splits
will acquire the locks
for making changes
to row X and y.
And then they will independently
talk to their replica
across the multiple zones.
So at this point, similar to
the previous single row case,
basically, they replicate the
data across the two other zones
for their split.
And then once they have
received acknowledgments
back from those two other
replicated split groups
from their group,
split 2 is going
to respond back to
the coordinator, which
is the split 1 in zone C, to say
that they are ready to commit.
At that point, because
split C is a coordinator,
it'll basically
tell split 2 to do
the commit of the
data, at which point
each group leader will then
tell its other replicas to apply
the change.
And the success is returned
back to the client.
So in this case,
the same protocol
that we were talking about
in the single row case
happens at each split level,
where each split leader informs
its other replicas
to apply the change
and to make the
proposal for the change.
But then there's coordination
among split leaders
on doing the commit
for all the rows
that are part of this commit.
So I know we covered
a lot of material,
but hopefully, it gave you
a sneak peek at, or at least
a better understanding at
how Cloud Spanner works
under the covers to get
external global consistency.
Stay tuned for a live Q&A. We'll
be back in less than a minute.
Welcome back.
We have a few questions that
we can go over with regard
to what we just discussed.
So let's get to them.
So first question, "How does
Spanner know which kind of read
the client is asking for,
and should this functionality
be built into the client?"
So yes, the question
was answered.
Basically, the
functionality is actually
built into the API,
where the API knows
where to route the read.
Also, the API itself,
when you make a request,
you can actually-- when you are
specifying bounded staleness,
it's part of the call.
Part of the request
that you make
is to say that I can
tolerate bounded staleness up
to, let's say, 15 seconds
or 10 minutes or whatever.
And because of that, it is
a pretty big hint to the API
that it should use the bounded
stale read request instead
of a strong read.
If you specify nothing
and just say, give me
key 1, value 1, then by default,
we give you the strong reads,
because we expect all
databases, relational databases,
we expect you to want
the consistent read
answer, the most freshest
read that just happened.
So hopefully, that answers that.
"Any plans to have a standalone
simulator to test Spanner?"
Yes, we have a plan for that.
Basically, we're working on
open sourcing our SQL engine
and the relevant parts
of it that will then
allow us to build a
simulator [AUDIO OUT]
be used locally on
machines and stuff.
And you don't have to constantly
be connected to the cloud.
And machines and stuff, and
you don't have to constantly
be connected to the cloud.
We're working on it,
and hopefully, we'll
have it soon enough.
Next question, "Does
Spanner support
column constraints such as
foreign key constraints?"
So so far, Spanner supports
foreign key constraints
in the form of
interleaved tables.
So basically, if you interleave
a table into a parent,
then that automatically gives
it a foreign-- a key constraint,
where you have to have
the parent in order
to have the child.
Well, beyond that, we don't
have foreign key constraints
in the product yet.
Hopefully-- we have
it in our backload,
and hopefully, we'll have
it sometime in the future.
So that's all the time we
had for questions today.
Hopefully, you enjoyed
the talk, and stay
tuned for talks coming every
Tuesday from Cloud OnAir
webinars from Google Cloud.
Thank you, and have a good day.